from lightsabers to the force and mind
tricks the Jedi are a force to be
reckoned with
even against the best of superheroes but
with the new Star Wars the last Jedi
trailer and movie coming out soon
not to mention EA's Battlefront 2
debacle we started wondering whether or
not the Jedi could actually exist
hypothetically could humans ever have or
obtain some of these capabilities first
up are the Jedi's incredible reflexes
which could be linked to seeing the
world in slow motion along with their
ability of foresight when you're put in
a dangerous or stressful situation time
often seems to slow down and this is
because your brain begins taking in much
more information than normal but even in
these moments your reflexes and time
perception hardly compare to some other
animals if you've ever tried to hit a
fly you might realize that what is a
really quick SWAT on your part is easily
avoided by the fly and that's because
the fly actually perceives it as slower
scientists use the point at which a
flickering light is seen as one
continuous light as a marker for visual
sensitivity and it turns out flies can
see light flickering at a rate nearly
seven times faster than we do for them
one second actually feels longer
scientists believe that perception of
time co-evolved with how fast an animal
moves how quick their metabolism is and
how big their bodies are after all it
doesn't make much sense for your brain
to take in so much information if your
body can't physically react to it in
time as a result leatherback turtles
only get about 1/3 of the information
that human brains do in one second dogs
on the other hand can see about 25%
faster than humans making our TVs look
like a set of flickering lights but with
improvements in vision sensitivity
jedi-like reflexes could become possible
but it would only matter if you could
physically react fast enough otherwise
you would just be seeing something come
towards you slowly with no means to
actually stop it while the force is a
somewhat mystical and elusive concept in
the movies it touches on some ideas that
scientists have long tried to explore
ancient Greeks actually believed in a
fifth element that connected everything
in the universe and even Isaac Newton
proposed a concept of our brains
interacting with something called ether
that was all around us which could
potentially give us psychic powers and
while the force is described in many
different ways
obi-wan suggests
it's an energy field created by all
living things it surrounds us penetrates
us it binds the Galaxy together this
sounds in some ways like the electric
fields that exist in and all around us
human brains for example emit brainwaves
a form of electromagnetic radiation that
travels at the speed of light this is
released from the activity of thousands
of neurons simultaneously firing at the
same frequency and many animals are
actually optimized to sense this
electricity like the platypus
it catches prey in murky waters at night
with their eyes ears and nostrils all
closed and instead using its bill
covered in nearly 40-thousand electro
receptors to detect the micro volts of
electricity that their prey emits even
human cells have the ability to detect
electric fields though not consciously
but perhaps with some genetic
engineering our acute awareness of this
force could become more pronounced
speaking of electricity many members of
the Sith are able to shoot lightning out
of their hands and there are certain
species of fishes that do something
similar consider the electric eel
capable of producing up to 600 volts of
electricity these fish have evolved
electric organs at least 100 million
years ago by converting muscle cells to
electro sites instead of simply
contracting to release a small amount of
voltage like normal muscle cells do
electro sites actually push ions across
a membrane in order to create a large
flow of positive charge ultimately
creating an electric current allowing
them to release a shock at will from
several feet away perhaps through gene
modification technologies like CRISPR a
version of these electro sites could be
created in humans allowing for electric
capabilities now theoretical physicist
Michio Kaku thinks that we do have the
materials and technology now to make a
lightsaber just those technologies need
to be upgraded light sabers are weapons
of powerful compact energy that can cut
through anything with a few exceptions
like another light saber dr. cash whose
design consists of a blade made from
superhot plasma one of the four
fundamental states of matter where air
is sucked into the base of the blade and
is superheated to create a six thousand
six hundred and forty-eight degrees
Celsius plasma an electromagnetic coil
would be used to control the plasma
while a telescopic ceramic rod which
shoots out of the handle and can resist
the
as temperature holds the blade all
together where does the energy come from
in the handle of the lightsaber are
trillions of nano batteries that power
the plasma generator and dr. Kaku thinks
of this technology could be ready in the
next 50 years the Star Wars film state
that those with a high midi-chlorian
count are actually much more in tune
with the force the D Florian's are a
microscopic life-form that resides
within all living cells they live inside
me George Lucas has suggested that this
was based on the idea of mitochondria an
organelle found in all eukaryotic
organisms that helped supply energy
cellular differentiation cell growth and
many other tasks and while most of your
cells have their own DNA in the cell
nucleus mitochondria actually have their
own genome in DNA which is more similar
to a bacteria lucas use this as a
metaphor for how without symbiosis
whether it sells or entire organisms
working together life couldn't exist now
if being more in tune with life simply
meant having more mitochondria it could
be as simple as doing more exercise a
study that had seniors complete a
12-week exercise program found that
skeletal muscle mitochondrial DNA
increased 53 percent after training of
course we have no real reason to believe
this would do much else unless George
Lucas knows something about the
mitochondria that scientists don't
George many Jedi are able to employ a
type of telekinesis through the force
and while there's been a lot of interest
in the idea of moving objects with your
mind scientific research has not
produced reliable repeatable
demonstrations of telekinesis so you
can't levitate an object with your mind
but we have been able to manipulate the
force with technology though it goes
against intuition non-magnetic
substances can be levitated within a
magnetic field physicists have been able
to levitate animals like this frog using
a high magnetic field as living things
consist of diamagnetic molecules like
water proteins and bones and the tiny
forces these molecules give off allow
them to levitate finally the Jedi are
able to use Jedi Mind Tricks to implant
suggestions which is perhaps most
closely linked to hypnosis in our world
the ability to respond to suggestions
it typically takes time to induce a
person into a hypnotic state and
hypnotizability itself is a spectrum
where not everyone responds but as we
move into the future and start
potentially putting technologies into
our brain another route may actually be
possible this mouse has fiber optic
cables wired into its right motor cortex
which controls movement to the left as
soon as the light is shot into its
altered neurons it cannot help but run
to the left its thoughts and actions
have been hacked as humans continue to
enhance their bodies and brains through
technology brain hacking akin to Jedi
Mind Tricks may become a major concern
connect to the reward centers of the
brain and now you can control how
someone feels everyone just wanted to
say thank you so much for watching we
don't communicate that often with you
guys on this channel but we just wanted
to say thank you so much for watching
everybody goes for almost six years we
really appreciate it and we are just so
happy that you guys are interested still
and learning with us if you want to
check out our Star Wars I capella will
put a link to that as well and also
click the bell we've been told people
get notified over them with the bell and
it really helps our Channel otherwise
subscribe and we'll see you soon
so Mario's say yes